bueno pues los comentarios al interior
de las redes sociales por parte de los
demócratas y por ejemplo en cabeza de la
encargada de la cámara de representantes
nancy pelosi pues muestran o piden que
no se haga un segundo debate ya que el
presidente de nación no puede seguir las
reglas esto debido a que en varias
oportunidades podemos ver cómo
interrumpía incluso al moderador
pero también hay críticas a como el
presidente aseguró no defender a los
supremacistas blancos o dio una
respuesta no muy clara al respecto y
esto encabeza los principales titulares
de la prensa sobre todo porque en las
redes sociales muchos grupos
supremacistas blancos salieron a
defender la respuesta del presidente de
donald trump por su parte bardem aseguró
que esta es una representación de lo que
el presidente de donald trump quiere
mostrar a la nación y es un presidente
que divide que crea conflicto y no
alguien que brinda soluciones y por
supuesto también hay muchos titulares
alrededor
la crisis de el coronavirus las
respuestas del presidente y los ataques
personales entre los dos el golpe más
bajo como califica la prensa de ese
ataque del presidente de donaldson hacia
el hijo de joe buck que podemos esperar
para el próximo debate el segundo para
el que no falta mucho y además sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta este antecedente
tan particular no
así es es un debate que se espera tenga
la misma dinámica en donde el público
pues tenga que tomarse una prueba de
coronavirus para poder asistir será un
público menor de 70 personas la mayoría
de sus estudiantes de la universidad de
solo incide en youtube y básicamente
pues este será el escenario perfecto
para discutir temas de la plataforma si
se puede llegar a realizar un debate
entre kamala harris y el vicepresidente
pensé en donde no haya tantos ataques
pues que muerto en sus plataformas sobre
todo para los más jóvenes por eso
escogieron este escenario de la
universidad de utah y también para
llegar a los votantes de la costa este
de los eeuu que tienen muchas preguntas
sobre la recuperación económica
igualmente se espera pues que en este
debate se den las mismas pautas de
discusión que sean segmentos de 15
minutos 6 segmentos en total y lo que
toca esperar para ver si los dos
candidatos a la vicepresidencia tendrán
digamos un sentido o un compromiso más
amplio para poder discutir sus
plataformas
no quedarse en la discusión bipartidista
gracias a viene acá tenida por este
reporte desde washington